das ist 60 aller streiks in den
unterlagen sind wusste baum geworfen
worden
von mirja ist schlink sie wissen gott
dann passierte stadt unter schock tränen
dass man gar nicht dass sie tot ist und
noch einmal ja das ist dann wirklich so
ist also wenn ich bin glaubt bin dann
vielleicht für das kleinere sachen zu
werden
ein schutzwall der geometrie und das
wird auch immer so viel freude und spaß
das haben wir wieder mehr finden ohne
jeweiligen aber dank mich wiedergefunden
oder und je länger je mehr also es ist
schon so was wird einfach obwohl es mir
so wie ihr ziel
[Musik]
david irving berlin starb anfang sommer
2015 einen monat nach ihrem tod ist
patrick mit raffael und leonie in den
noch gemeinsam geplanten ferien einen
teil von evelyn tasche haben sie
mitgenommen
[Musik]
münchen die ganze quartier ein
mich gibt es
[Musik]
bis 11
diese
das erste jahr ohne evelyn war für die
familie sehr schwierig evelyn verstarb
völlig unerwartet an einer schweren
hirnblutungen
zwei monate nach ihrem tod ist es für
die familie immer noch so wie wenn es
gestern passiert wäre
die idee dachte ich halt noch nicht
immer der fall
und plötzlich als natürlich darauf ob
sie plötzlich habe ich zu wenig hört
dann habe ich dachte ich weiß was
passiert ich ihnen bestehen ist dann hat
der vorgang vor der 12 ich bin ein
fingerdruck zum flüge aus damit handy
gestellt was er macht und haben dann
noch nicht gestanden ist dass das haben
wir zum tod von rebellen kontrolliert
und dass es ganz schrecklich so etwas
passiert ist ja und dann im ersten
moment dass sie falsch verstanden
gleichzeitig sah patrick auf dem handy
dass ihn sein schwager mehrmals versucht
hatte zu erreichen
zerstört will dir das nummer und dann
hat mich patrick kubisch
und dann sagt du ich bin roma vor sieben
kapoor ich bin natürlich verstehen die
gef luchse was ist passiert
derzeit hat er sicher bis passiert
wirklich stimmt dass berlin gestorben
war
ich glaube dass noch alle sagt dann sage
ich zum beispiel einfach zu sagen ist
das war bestimmt das sagt man das jetzt
irgendwie bis mit dem finden was ist mit
der ebeling
der kurzzeitige stimmt klinik verstorben
aber das sind ganz gut
unter der dachmarke statt
ich habe das als wunder ist gesagt haben
dass es erst mal nicht glaubt
doch es ist sich selbst um einfach gut
und sie kommen verschluckt und das
merken wir sind und die sind in
sicherheit und passiert
ein bisschen der familie
[Musik]
angrick sie geht der familie den seligen
bürokratisch im taxi oder erstaunlich
damit sie ja sie hat die sicherheit
vermittelt marc wissmann sieht euch dann
läuft und das ist jetzt weg bis zur
kreation wurde evelyn aufgebaut um sich
von ihr zu verabschieden nahm patrick
die kinder mit wir sind damit möchte ich
möchte mich gemacht
ein wichtiger schritt im ganzen prozess
ihnen ihr kind einfach mal rein und
haben jetzt na ja das ist mein motto
lied und was ist mit mami aber erlaubt
eine stütze
sodann auch einen abschließen
das ist für mich ganz bewegender moment
sie die beiden sind wir sind auf dem
friedhof frau und frau und das mami
familie weiterhin es jetzt bärtiger das
ist für mich ganz schlimm dass wir keine
wahl hatte und dann plötzlich die vielen
urteil am tisch extrem groß sie was hat
ihr viel erfolg
ich weiß nicht was passiert ist aber ich
weiß dass es ganz einfach viel viel für
sich und irgendwann offen bis zur
fertigung so gut und es ist sehr traurig
und einsam ist sehr groß und dann nach
der beerdigung schäden wie abgeschlossen
quasi fertig
und ja man hat wieder mal tagen
also müssen plötzlich als sie den
sommerferien sie alle sind die fälle
komme und mich in ihr taxi der evonik
wie gefangen
das haus vorher in berlin
das sind 100 dem sagte bonhof
der große administrative aufwand nach
der beerdigung zwingt patrick zurück in
den alltag
ein auto sektor ihren befehlen sein was
alles mündiger wer braucht alles und
sterbeurkunde verbrauch der todes
bestätigt und weiblicher schriftlich
oder elektronisch nach und davor
du bist total verloren wir jetzt einfach
extrem auf einer schaffe gerade zweiter
mir gehts weiter
ich mache ich das jetzt lagen wie
schaffe ich das wie bringe ich wie wenig
kind und mir übertrieben dass man mich
stark genug bin ich ganz offen
wie schätzt du musst hier reduzieren
ja eine reduzierte mir finanziert eine
familie sind alles tausende folgen
gewarnt oder carl cox ist nach einem 2 5
schwierigkeit ist christi wenn man mir
zum beispiel zeigt dieser woche zwei
später noch schützt du eigentlich gar
nicht überschätzt zwei wochen hayward
nach hinten
sind die verarbeiter beide ganz
unterschiedlich leoni sieht jetzt sehr
glücklich auch dass sie schon sehr oft
vor dem motto wir haben da bis jetzt
etwas drauf wo er sofort da kommt auch
nach ablenkung und ständiges machen und
unterhaltung seit dem tod der mutter
fürchtet sich leoni vor der nacht ohne
ihren vater neben sich kann sie nicht
einschlafen
ein seltsames wesen sich das den gang
schneidet willige massen und gibt dabei
die furchtbarsten laute von sich
bu ergo
der grund der antragsstau haben und was
ist eigentlich ganz wie es auch schon
komisch
das ist sowieso bereits jetzt einfach
dass ich sport mache mache ich das
tagebuch geschrieben
ich muss nicht mehr los erhalten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
drei monate sind seit dem großen verlust
vergangen
patrick hat wieder angefangen als
intensivpflege fachmann im flugdienst
erreger zu arbeiten
mehr schwagstorf ist schon nicht einfach
gesehen will ich trank schmerzen werden
der serie nimmt ein kind
erstmals ist mit dir und das ist für
mich schon riesig cma von einfach zu
wissen wie htc und schlussendlich zog
sich eigentlich noch zwei altman pause
und dann wieder fröhlich stieger bin
patricks mutter ist früh verstorben
freundinnen der familie und seine
schwiegermutter unterstützen ihnen bei
der kinderbetreuung
die großmutter der kinder ist
gesundheitlich angeschlagen seit einer
operation ist die kehlkopf los
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
noch mehr große zurück in zukunft mit
gittern
die dynamik zur standard sie sind elf
also sicher mit langsam mit mit patina
mann gottes wieder normale alltag in
meinestadt.de und die regler wo man wo
man früher hat das mito enthalten
[Musik]
das ist eigentlich das nickel steigen
ich bin ich gespannt das wirklich
leuchtet
[Musik]
es gibt touren schon wo der unterschied
gar nicht können auch zu mir kommen
irgendwo wurde nicht weil die christen
und evelyn hat das gerät verkauft da bin
ich dann zu kommen was aber angestellt
ist das in paris erklärt die upd zweimal
ich bin seit über sechs zehn oder elf
titel stellen und zeigen es vielleicht
einmal spannend geworden
das erste mal gestellt
der ruf von abbott ist schwer das muss
ich glaub amerika schwierige situationen
gibt es immer wieder mal angst
spitzenrestaurants ins kiesbett und die
wand lösen und oftmals ist dann so dass
dann in mir sagt ja wie man es besser
gesehen und bin hammad osteifel und und
repetierte grafischen blätter papier und
das sind also situationen wo nicht
einfach an mir verbindungen ab machen
zum beispiel
seitdem ist sie glaube ich ein ganz
schlechter schlafen im moment und dann
ist klar dass sie mutig vor geistig sehr
standhaft ruhig schlafen für leoni leoni
[Musik]
kommen nicht drum herum
das mekka für alle unterschätzten ist so
bitter dass wir haben einfach gemerkt
dass das mir hilft dass es ohne hilfe
fast nicht gut und ich bin freundlich
ein kinderpsychologe kunden womit auf
dem weg nach wie vor das problem und das
ist schwierig mit ihm schlafen macht man
jetzt wieder gemacht
ich sehe also das ist ja das mit termin
zu spielen und das machen was sie
schätzten das hass spiel gebracht
was ist
rossi stand die box muss
die gefühlsschwankungen der kinder
verunsichern ihren vater kinder trauern
anders als erwachsene
die therapeutin hilft beiden seiten
einander zu verstehen
koch
ja
[Musik]
es ist herbst geworden energie selber
auf menschen zuzugehen hat patrick nicht
er ist froh hat sich thorsten ein
bekannter aus der kirchgemeinde bei ihm
gemeldet
dorstens frau ist vor gut zwei jahren an
krebs gestorben
es ist wirklich sexy wir haben zwischen
seelenverwandter trafen eigentlichen in
opladen günstig muss im grunde weiß
genau wie ich mich fühle
bis mir gott was ich jetzt immer man da
noch zahlreiche tore gemacht oder
[Musik]
ich liebe sie cathy informieren
es ist so schlimm ist wie die farben
immer wieder
ich brauch teil wissen auch doof und ich
träume vor dem und die situationen die
kommt immer wieder rufen das schon okay
das ist einfach pech
was macht der alte witz in der bibel in
ortslage ich habe mir trost oder halt
gibt ich habe das immer wieder versucht
im moment ist für mich einfach
ja es ist mir noch mal um kraft ich
verstehe verstarb im moment nicht ich
verstehe die zweifel und die das gefühl
ich verstehe gott nicht mit dem was ich
an bild von von gott hatte passt das
jetzt überhaupt nicht zusammen ich
glaube die zeit als ich meine frau
verloren hat war einfach wie ein kampf
mal ums überleben und wo ich merkte
andere haben für mich geglaubt
andere waren einfach da sage ich ohne
gott die beste zeit
es brauche teil des rechten fleisch und
blut wo es beobachtet ganz kühl das
funktioniert und wir sind jetzt fertig
wenn jetzt ist es vorbei
die endlichkeit zum bruder und mich das
soll auffällig vorher aber das personal
fehlt ich war eigentlich immer noch
organisiert hat wo es wird da eigentlich
alles erwartet dass mein kind aber bei
mir missbrauchen
und das ist ja das ist möglich
lospech nicht weißt was du musst nicht
so mit mir reden wieder mit den kollegen
außerdem blitzstart in dem mitschnitt
die wärme
das ist für mich im moment eigentlich im
vorteil ist nichts wissen sie was ich
jetzt und das muss man auch zurück für
verluste
der besuch als ehrengäste an einem fcz
match dass das leid für kurze zeit
vergessen
möglich gemacht hat dies der verein
sterntaler welcher familien in not
kleine glücks inseln verschafft
o
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die erste weihnachtszeit ohne evelyn ist
für patrick und die kinder nicht einfach
[Applaus]
wenn ich fragen kurz das herausdrehen
los los
mit ihnen
lasst sie vielleicht schreibt sinn der
grund zu laufen
ich merke ich zwei tagen im monat flüge
des materials und 7 ich brauche das ich
muss meinen kopf wieder fehlt mit
anderen das auch und ich habe getroffen
die energie hier oder die situation die
heidfeld ich wollte den besten denn ja
okay ich hab es stimmig sind minarette
es war ein hin und ein geworden
christa wenn du mir sagen ich mach jetzt
klingt wirklich extrem uhr das wirklich
wollen sie mit mehr mut aber das kids
etwas terminiert das mache derzeit die
möglichkeit bei halles ich weiß dass da
will in traditionsreicher mannschaft
hätten wir noch dass er werden kann
sie fällt noch so kleinen fehler gemacht
und noch dazu war das nur stadtrat
übertroffen
dass die spiele für für die aufstocker
ich mache mir immer mit gelernt gewalt
macht man sich schwierigen zeiten
erinnert und so stehen kann das zeigt
diese eigentlich funktionieren
watch it systemhaus
[Musik]
langsam wird es frühling
patrick hat sein pensum bei der rega
reduziert und wird dafür teilzeit auf
einer intensivstation arbeiten
das erleichtert ihnen die organisation
der kinderbetreuung der erde zieht in
der kapelle und will ich mir gemerkt
dass ich bin erfolgreich mit zwei und
ich danke jetzt wo man ja im alltag auto
sind selten irgendwo wo man muss auch an
optimieren und die haben nicht vorher
ein neuanfang für leoni sie bekommt ein
neues bett ihr vater hofft dass sie sich
dann wieder wohlfühlt in ihrem zimmer
und alleine schlafen kann
[Applaus]
und dann geschieht das am besten passt
[Musik]
auch knapp ach so ballack
ja was im rauch fisches moment bei so
dass sehr viele zwei nicht braucht also
es ist möglich dass europa jetzt wieder
erholt ich möchte schon einfach
unheimlich mir ein icon ist ein offener
und auch drei wenig sie hat nach
ablenkung echtheit der humanen irgendwo
stellen sie selbstständiger bis märz
laufen im alltag und man merkt es an
autobahn-baustellen und die städte
beschlossen bis machen was er vorher
nicht können aber unsere homepage
[Musik]
ich find's cool fokus
das wichtigste wenn tiere eigentlich im
umgang mit trend dass marine was man
ihnen bekräftig geht oder dass man nicht
vor man versucht ja sieben termine das
gefühl jetzt mein treuer schulen wieder
so integrieren und chaos
das eine uhr/live-ticker bringt und wenn
nicht dann hat es konsequent sondern
hollemann nachhilfe
[Musik]
es hilft vielleicht was man sich noch
besser vorstellen kann jede schule bin
ich mir unkonzentriert und dann wieder
gut
also schätze dass extremisten sind die
zeit gibt
ich habe einfach angst dass man sind
nach wie vor geschätzt wurde
die million mit dem merkt das
stadtinnere durfte stirn geschrieben ich
habe vor kurzem meine mami verloren 2
nur stockfleth am lager die schöne trug
während er mit der freizeitcard zum 3
was vor
ja leider so möglich die schwierigkeiten
sich lernt viele verschiedene
[Musik]
max eberl ja ein problem sind dass eine
person sich perfekt und so erklären sich
auch öffnen
man merkt dass das oftmals wirklich
furchtbar
droht ein vorfall ich habe mir als
einfach sein
süße träume und wünsche die muss ich es
umsetzen will das könnte irgendwann
sport sie das können sie erste ausfahrt
sie
ein
nein
[Musik]
hallo
die organisation der kinderbetreuung
bleibt nach wie vor eine herausforderung
ok ja ich kann das problem und zwar ist
es so dass großeltern auf kind aufpasst
hand und unseren stand hunt in der
kinderbetreuung das jetzt als grund
deutlicher gründen per sofort und ich
haben sie wähle konkret aufregende
möglichkeit gibt das kind manager
interview
[Musik]
wird patrick emmel ins lieblingsmusik
fühlt er sich ihr nah ein jahr leben er
und die kinder nun schon ohne sie
[Musik]
das ist durch bin sehr gut verarbeitet
nach wie vor schuldig fühlt das rund
obwohl ich eigentlich wirklich weiß ist
schätzen wir können verhindern versuchen
7823 und im moment ist das so dass ich
wenn ich wach wird das thema sich die
richtig vorankommen und 5300 devil and
enforcement oder
gibt es los und ja ich auch noch nicht
reif dafür denn dort 7 sowie ein prozent
besser
ob ich sitze sowie im moment geht dann
so wenn du zum beispiel spielständen nur
schlachten oder sondern ich denke schon
dass man ihn wieder führen also immer
wenn du traurig bist darum diese wieder
führen
ich freue mich für ihn über das thema
reden und sie tröstet mich dann auch
darum bedeutet dass ich viel also ich
bezogener vor das kind richtig machen
jedes ob sie morgen will ich mir kommen
beispielsweise darauf haben zweiter tag
nach dem tod des hauses und fußball
gespielt wo sie jetzt im nachhinein
sagen hey das genauso ich sie will für
den hat es gestimmt zumal
also war ich mir nicht vorstellen dass
man mit monats stand das thema noch
nicht wie am anfang das hat sich nicht
verändert
mittlerweile ist das du anbieten
oder einfach löschen die korrekte
erinnerung
[Musik]
zusammen mit der familie gedenke patrick
und die kinder der vor einem jahr
verstorbenen evelyn nicht alle menschen
in ihrem umfeld haben verstanden dass
sich die familie bei ihrem trauerprozess
filmen lässt der ausschlag hätten die
punkte eigentlich sie dass das sich
rebellin will mir so viele andere
mannschaft und haus wo viel ist man in
eine ähnliche situation in filmen können
aufzeigen dass gottes kommt mal wieder
die tour dienst bewältigen
das wird besser mit bezieht
[Musik]
es gibt kein der truhe der schmerz dass
von hinten noch hilft ist wirklich man
sieht wenn man das sehr gern
beschleunigen tötet am anfang das geld
[Musik]